That should remind us where we should be
standing up.
Teddy Roosevelt said, "It is not the
critic who counts,
not the man who points out how the
strong man stumbles or where of the
deeds could have done it better."
The credit belongs to the man who is
actually in the arena whose face is
marred by dust, sweat, and blood. Who
strives valently
who errors and comes up short again and
again
because there's no effort without error
or shortcoming.
But who knows the great enthusiasm, the
great devotion, who spends himself in a
worthy cause, who at the best knows in
the end triumph of a triumph of high
achievement. And who at the worst if he
fails at least he fails while do daring
greatly so that his place will never be
with those cold and timid souls who ne
knew neither victory nor defeat. I
couldn't have said it any better than
Teddy Roosevelt himself. Islam is not a
spectator religion.
Allahh reminds us
Strive for Allah with striving with the
striving that is due to Allah subhana wa
ta'ala.
Better a believer bruised by truth than
untouched by it. Malcolm was not an
important was not important because he
was angry. Many people are angry. He was
important because he changed after
encountering Islam. Malcolm said I was
wrong. Those are not weak words. Those
are Islamic words. Allah praises those
who grow when the truth becomes clearer.
Allah subhana t says
those who listen to what is said and
follow the best of it. Islam took fire
and gave it a direction.
My young brothers and sisters,
do not let this world convenience you.
The faith is weakness.
The conscience is a liability and
silence is maturity.
Allah subhana t reminds us in the Quran
the story of the people of the kaf.
Allah says they were young people who
believed in their lord
and we increase them in guidance. Youth
Islam in Islam is not a waiting room.
It's a launching pad. Malcolm said we
can think of uniting we cannot think of
uniting with others while we unite
amongst ourselves.
Our children will ask us, they will ask
us where we stood.
Allah subh reminds us in the Quran that
he does not change the condition of
people until those people change their
own conditions.
Do not shrink. Do not disappear. Stand
upright.
Malcolm is Malcolm today because he
stood up for what was right.
A man who stood up for justice and
courage even though it cost him his
life. For most of us, Malcolm is just a
figure that appears in the books and
that's it.
Yet, the true injustice lies in a in a
system where MLK is celebrated by a
national holiday and Malcolm is just
pushed in the back of the syllabus
books.
A man who died at the age of 39
where 40 years old, the human intellect
kicks into the man's intellect kicks
into a high gear.
a man who was very well-versed even
though he was an eighth grade dropout,
but he spoke most eloquently than a lot
of PhDs and scholars today. A man who
spoke at the Oxford Union,
the epitome of the Anglosaxon,
we made it.
If any of us ever get to that level, you
just get a standing ovation for walking
in the room that you've made it to the
Oxford Union.
This man, Re Niche
Spinosa Chopenhau
Malcolm said, "There's hardly a person I
know who benefited more from prison than
I did."
You see the divine hand in this man's
life. How Allah subhana ta guided
Malcolm to the path.
Yes, Malcolm stood for black
nationalism. But he struggled with it
when he came back from his hajj. When he
returned from Mecca, Malcolm struggled
greatly with the word black nationalism
because he saw Muslims who were white.
He saw Muslims who were blonde hair and
greeneyed. He saw Muslims from Africa
and Muslims from from Turkey.
And that word no longer made sense to
him.
And dare I say, people me who today
have the courage to stand and speak and
to show up in places and ask for our
rights.
Though right, those rights were not
given to us. Those rights have been
paved. That road to those rights have
been paved by the blood and the souls of
those who stood before us on the path,
people Malcolm
who spoke about injustices from American
streets to Philstine
and the world over.
And that's the reason today Makob
doesn't have a national holiday
but MLK does.
We are at a crossroads of history in our
lives.
Our children will ask us 10, 15, 20
years from today, what did you do?
Where were you?
telling them that I chose to be silent
and I chose to be quiet. It's not going
to be the part that we want.
Don't get me wrong, the path some of us
chosen to speak about and to educate
others is not the path for everybody.
And I don't expect everybody to be on
that path.
The least I can do is educate and leave
something behind that will give you the
hope.
If the masjid is not a safe place, then
I don't know what will be a safe place
to speak about the injustices that we
have amongst ourselves.
The prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
taught us there's three levels of faith.
The first is we change something that is
disliked by our hands. The second is the
tongue. And the third, the lowest level
of that is we think in our heart it is
wrong.
The today has lost the plot.
Allah sallallahu alaihi wasallam did not
create passive people.
He created people who stood upright.
Let me bring it back and try to conclude
on this note.
A while after the Sahaba had migrated to
Medina and things had settled down, the
Sahaba one day gathered and asked,
"Yeah, why did he used to say a
and Bal said, "I didn't know anything
else. All I knew is that one word would
one word would irate the mushik of Mecca
beyond its control. Every time I said
it would tick them further. Every time I
return after they hit me or they stabbed
me or they put me on hot stones and hot
sand, it will keep turning the pressure
on their anger. They will get more and
more furious with me.
And that's all I knew.
I know a lot of us have that question in
our mind, but I don't know what to do.
We all have an answer what to do. We all
have a in us the beloved Allah who left
behind for us. All of us have that.
So as we depart today,
I remind you of your moral
responsibility
and these are not my words. This is what
Allahh and his prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam has said.
We have a choice of what kind of Muslim
do we need to be or what Muslim looks
or who we are.
The Islam that spread around the world
was never spread on the tip of the
sword. But it was spread by the justice,
the humility
and the self-consciousness of Muslims.
We ask Allah subhana tala to make us one
of the people who hears his word and
hears the words ofam and becomes the
best imitator.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Standing is not rage.
Standing is righteousness.
Allahh reminds us in the Quran
or you believe if you support Allah, he
will support you and make your feet
firm.
Allah does not promise ease.
He promises firm feet.
And Allah reminds us again in the Quran,
indeed Allahh commands you with justice
and excellence.
Justice does not justice without mercy
becomes cruelty.
Mercy without justice becomes weakness.
And that's why Islam commands both.
To my youth,
build discipline before popularity,
character before influence, faith before
fear, and never trade your
consciousness, your Islam, or your
dignity for acceptance.
I've said this many times before and
I'll repeat it again.
When Allah subhana ta looked at each one
of us in the
and he chose us to be a Muslim. It was
not a mistake.
Allah subhana t looked at each one of
our souls
and said this soul is the best soul to
carry my message
and he didn't place you in the foreign
lands because he hated you
or because you were thirdass Muslim or
you're a weak Muslim. He put you there
because he saw you as somebody who can
complete the responsibility of
[Arabic recitation]
Each one of us
has a calling. Each one of us what we
call has a why.
Why do I do this? And it is our job to
find the why. Allah is not going to
provide the answer.
When Allah subhana t says that he's
going to aid us,
he means by the avenues that are around
us.
I'm often reminded of the verses
from Bakar when Allah subhana t decides
to to create Adam and the have a
conversation with Allah subhanaa tala
and says why are you creating a a a
human being who's going to create
destruction and Allah says I know
something
I know something that you do not know
and
used to remind us that when Allah said
that he did did not need a person
sitting in the masid all day saying
subhan allah subhan allah subhan allah
he needed somebody who was balanced who
would go and take care of the people and
the responsibility and still connect
with Allah subhana tala and one of them
is not prioritized over the other
when Allahh calls us a middle nation
that's what middle nation means we're
neither to the left or the
We are balanced people
who speak balanced truth
even if it is against ourselves.
I remind you of the instance mentioned
in the hadith when a woman from an upper
tribe was caught stealing in the Medina
and the tribe people came to and tried
to convince him to let
the let her go without cutting her hands
said even if it was my own daughter
I would have chopped her hand that's in
that's
justice even it affects ourselves else.
People
around you are struggling.
Your children are struggling without you
knowing.
We have an identity crisis amongst our
youth.
Our communities are scattered
and we choose not to speak about these
issues
because a lot of times for us it's
inconvenient
or choose not to stand for these truths
because it's inconvenient.
We choose to ignore them.
Just because a bird sees the the the cat
approaching on the tree branch and
closes his eyes, the cat doesn't
disappear.
That threat is as real as it was before.
Create safe spaces
around you. Uplift people. Do not
destroy people.
My job and your job. Allah will never
ask me or ask you what the other person
did. It will ask what I did. I have to
be answerable for my conscience and you
have to be answerable for your
conscience. And as such, we have to do
that.
As we close, we ask Allah subhana ta to
give us the insight
to be people who will stand upright come
Monday morning
and people who will practice our faith
outside these four sacred walls
and stand upright and speak for every
single person who doesn't have a voice
and be a guide
and a shining light in the darkness of
the darknesses.
We ask Allah subhana ta to make us from
the people who unite hearts and not
divide hearts. We ask Allahh to make us
one people who unite not divide the
we ask Allah subhana tala that he
makes us from those folks that wasallam
will be feeding the water of the the
from his hands to us.
for
[Silence]
Allah.
forch.
[Silence]
Allahbar.
Just make sure back of your foot is on
the white line behind you. Your row will
be straightened automatically just the
back of your foot shoulder to shoulder.
Make sure all the rows are filled in
front of you before you start on your
row. Inshallah. May Allah subh have
mercy upon us. Amen.
Allahbar.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
for
amen. coming
Allah.
Fore!
Foreign! Foreign!
[Silence]
Allah
say
Fore!
Foreign! Foreign!
for
[Silence]
Allah abbar.
Allahbar.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Amen.
for
[Silence]
Fore.
S Allah
Allahbar.
[Silence]
Stop. Stop.
Brothers and sisters, asalam allaykum, I
just want you to have some patience with
me today because I got few things to
cover and hopefully that information
will be helpful to all of us inshallah.
First of all, I want to thank Imam
Hassan for
his five years with this community. He
served this community for five years and
most of us if you ask you know how long
has he been there they can you may not
be able to get a right answer but it has
been alhamdulillah long five you know
good five years and it went by fast
we wish him the very best and inshallah
he'll be just not not too long too
far away he'll be in Phoenix area
inshallah and you will be able to see
him periodically and maybe he can visit
us again he's welcome to come back
anytime and see us and see his community
here inshallah. We wish him the very
best in his new job.
Now there are couple of things that
follow up on what we have to do. There
are a couple of programs that Imam
Hassan was running youth program and the
Sunday school program. Both of those
program has been is going are going to
be led by our Imam Hassan inshallah and
he is committed to
I'm sorry she Ali Imam Ali will be the
one who will be leading the two of the
both of those programs. I certainly
apologize I just switched the names here
because I've been having difficulty
between the two brothers here in me in
in remembering the names. But anyway,
Imam Ali will be leading the both
programs, the Sunday program and the
[Arabic recitation]
Now the Rama Academy is also looking for
a teacher. So if you have somebody who
interested, please talk to Jabra Jabra.
Now that brings me to something very
important. By this time every year we
had some good success in getting the
pledges for the Rahma Academy. That
means diverting the state of Arizona
liabilities to the masjid to the Rahim
Academy. And this year we are running a
little slow here. So please take a look
at it and see what you can do. I
understand the tax season is just
beginning here. So please help us in
getting those numbers as strong as we
can to benefit the Rahama Academy.
Now let me talk about the Ramadan. The
according to the Imam Council of
Arizona, the TAVAI will be on Wednesday
night,
pardon,
[Arabic recitation]
first Ramadan will be the 19th.
So, inshallah, you will see the schedule
posted. That leads me to the next
subject here. We are going to be looking
for people who could help us sign up
for the iftar. And the ifar expenses,
it'll be during the weekday. It's going
to be $2,000.
On the weekend, it will be $3,500. And
you can talk to brother Jabber. There's
a detail all posted on the wall here.
see what you can do to sign up for that.
And our tavi will be led by Imam Ali.
and
half is dari and half is aim inshallah.
So you'll have a pleasure of having
three of leading the prayers inshallah
and we'll be having a very very
spiritual
Ramadan inshallah. So looking forward
to that inshallah. on the way out
please donate generously for your
masidam.
Again my apologies to Imam
Mixing the nails.